I had a certainly libertarian side I
supported Ron Paul for a while when I
was younger I believe it or not you may
be surprised that I was a Republican and
I supported Goldwater in 64 I don't
agree with donors positions now you know
that life changes you change your
opinions as you go I think the very
Goldwater generation relied on a level
of conservatism that still trusted the
state to be involved in a lot of their
beliefs and to enforce and give their
ideas legitimacy but I think that
Millennials are independent thinkers and
they're willing to think for themselves
and to see that I actually don't need
the state to enforce my ideas for them
to be true we're actually seeing a
second wave of libertarianism right now
that diverges from the first wave the
libertarianism of the 1940s through the
1990s we no longer have the threat of
communism as an ever-present concern
we're able to tackle attacks on Liberty
from many different directions now this
is a philosophy that's embedded in you
know the way life really is it's to say
it's naive is naive itself the people
who are here are really dedicated to
these ideas and it's inspiring to see
that level of dedication and I find it
very hard to believe that suddenly we'll
all wake up when we're 26 and decide to
become status people are very used to
this idea of you know government doing
whatever they want behind the curtains
behind the scene and we are a generation
that we are a little bit more aware than
before I think there are so many
resources and tools available to people
now especially young people that it can
be something that sticks you know they
have resources through organizations
like the Institute for Humane studies
networks like SFL they won't end up
alone somewhere without intellectual
ammo or community I have a printing
business in Argentina so I brought some
over there I did the Enron pop art so I
also did like Keep Calm forbid thing
we're a more socially open we're more
tolerant group and that's more appealing
to the people specifically on the left
the older libertarians did a good job
bringing people on the right into the
movement and now we're coming in and
we're bringing the left in is